when did you start thinking about a
career outside of dance well here's the
funny thing it's like you know I got
married when I was uh 20 years old I had
a son and I was married at 20.
um so I was I actually retired as a
dancer
when I was 24.
[Music]
I stopped dancing but
I put all my time into doing
choreography
um and then I got a regular nine to five
job so the regular nine to five job and
the reason why I stopped dancing is
because as a dancer you cannot control
when rehearsals will be you can't
control the days of rehearsal the hours
of rehearsal as a choreographer I could
though so I can still have a regular
nine-to-five job and then work my
rehearsals around my nine to five job
that's why I only did that and again I
had a wife I had a son I needed to have
a steady income benefits health
insurance that kind of stuff so that's
why I got a regular nine to five job
um so I never left Dancing but
um
um you know I was already thinking about
a life after dance
because of this regular nine-to-five job
now
I went from a dancer to a choreographer
to working in you know
um Corporate America
um and then I quit my corporate American
job
um this was after my kids were grown
when my youngest turned 18 I'm like okay
well my kids are grown that part's done
if I never got married if I never had
any kids what would I be doing right now
I said I would be directing
so that's when I decided to quit my I
was working for the city of San Juan
Capistrano really good paying job
working for a city you know benefits
pension the whole shebang quit that job
lost my girlfriend after I quit that job
she's like um what are you doing
yeah I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to this
small community college here and learn
how to write how to direct I want to be
director what so she's like um
we're you know in our 40s we can't
really you know I I can't have that am I
okay well that's fine you know so she
left and so I went ahead and enrolled to
a community college in South Orange
County California and I was there for
about a year and a half I wasn't there
to get a degree I was there because I
wanted to learn how to write how to
direct just give me the basics I could
take it from there and then um when I
was there I did a uh a short film and
that's what got me uh my rep my it's
it's called reparation it's a musical
and that's what got me my managers so
I've had maybe about four or five
different careers you know over the over
over a lifespan and did pretty well with
all of them and I was you know I got
what I needed from each of them and I've
learned so much from different people
different backgrounds and I think it
helps me with my writing and it helps me
with my directing
and why not still work for the city of
San Juan Capistrano and then take night
classes or weekends yeah because the
film classes that I had were not at that
time they were not at times that were
convenient for those who were going who
had a regular nine to five these I mean
these These are you know we look at
Community College typically these are
kids who just finished high school so
these are 18 year olds and so they're
not necessarily
um
um looking at the fact that they that
you may have a nine to five with heavy
responsibility so it's like it was it
was either that or don't go to school so
I decided that I wanted to do that I had
some money saved up so I lived on the
savings and towards the end it got
pretty tough my car got repossessed I
mean it was it was tough at the very end
um but I was so close to finishing it
and I was doing you know this thesis
project so
that got done
um so no I couldn't I couldn't do both
at the same time I did do like other
audience jobs you know I ubered I did I
I was I worked as a PA I was which is a
camera assistant I did a lot of other
jobs while I was still in school to make
money so it wasn't like I was just
sitting on my on my um savings but you
know I had a BMW at the time I had a
pretty expensive house I was living in
Irvine you know it was it those areas
aren't cheap because again I was making
a lot of money at the time working for
the city so yeah
um
it towards the end it hurt really bad in
regards to money losing my girlfriend in
the whole shebang but
um you know and even that first year you
know it was tough uh first year and a
half I would say was tough because again
I did a lot of auditing jobs in the
entertainment business because again
that's where I wanted to be but you're
not making a lot of money with some of
these you know some of the grunt work
stuff that you do uh in fact for a good
year I was an editor I edited a lot of
music not music videos I did a lot of
videos for YouTube influencers like
people like six seven million followers
for like makeup tutorials and other kind
of weird quirky little things
um because I could work from home and I
can write so that's what I did I did
that for about a year a year and a half
and you know making
300 per video when I would do probably
around five videos a week of editing so
1500 bucks you know I was doing my best
to kind of keep things going and stuff
and and you know I got I finally got the
opportunity
um to write and direct you know
um a Christmas movie
do you remember the day you gave your
resignation at your corporate job or
your date time yeah I remember that day
and they were very surprised because for
them to come out of nowhere because I
never really had spoken to anybody there
and told them what I had planned on
doing
um and they were surprised and they were
shocked and they're like okay what's you
know why they said well because I'm
gonna go back to school
um to to write and direct and they were
like what yeah you know again you have
the security of the pension the whole
shebang and yeah those are all fantastic
things but I know me and the issue I was
going to have is this I was never going
to reach my full potential
if I still had one foot in the corporate
world because I knew that if things got
tough for me I would always just be able
to fall back into that so I know I
needed to jump in with both feet and
almost starve myself to to push myself
to be there the best that I can be in in
regards to writing and directing and
taking the classes that I need to take
to like learn how to how to do what I
needed to do in order to make movies
um so that's kind of what I did like
even when I write today I write like
this is my only job I only right now
only direct now I don't have any other
side jobs
um and I just came to that realization
that I was able to do that in 2020. no
2019 was the first year I was like you
know what I can actually do this and not
worry about taking another job like that
was the first time that I did it we felt
really good to be to to get to that
point but to that I was terrified and so
I did a lot of writing I write out of
fear even today I still write out a fear
my and the fear is oh this is my last
job I'll never be able to work again so
that's another reason why I have no
problems in writing the 15 pages because
it's like either this or Stars
you know I I but I know that I needed me
I need to put myself in that mental
headspace
in order for me to push myself to get to
where I am today and that's why you know
since 2018 I've directed over 22
Episodes of TV and three and three made
for TV movies because of the fact that
I've I've pushed myself to that corner
where I've I have to fight to get out
and the only way to do that is to do
what I need to do which is writing and
directing
what kind of conversations were you
having with yourself when you said you
were living in Irvine you had a nice car
you had this safe quote-unquote job
were you going like on lunch hour and
and saying you know what these people
are all really nice but this isn't for
me and I need to get out of here it's
funny when I came to the point of saying
you know what I'm done with corporate
world I want to do this writing directly
thing
it actually came out of out of anger and
frustration because
I knew there was something missing
already in my life in regards to getting
back into the Arts I wasn't going to
dance I wasn't going to choreograph
anymore I knew that so I knew I wanted
to jump into the right of the writing
and directing so it was not a hard
difficult decision at all I see so even
all the all the trappings of success it
wasn't worth it to you if you're waking
up on Monday mornings not wanting to go
into the office yeah yeah and that you
know I you're right I did not want to be
in the office number one even if the
money was okay and you know and here's
the thing I looked at it this way like
okay I'm making okay let's let's I'm
gonna say what I was making but let's
say I'm making 75 000 a year plus I get
a pitch in plus I get benefits that's
great okay it's not a lot of money
especially in California it's not a lot
of money it's okay I was living in South
Orange County it's not a lot of money in
Southwest County uh number one number
two I'm like this is my ceiling I'm like
I'm limiting myself like as a writer and
as a director like the numbers are
Limitless
so do I want this steady
with a with a ceiling or do I want to
yeah a little more dangerously but have
this not have the ceiling on me and so
like I said after that first year it was
tough and I'm like oh I mean there was a
lot of times that I would go back and
take a look at okay what jobs are
available a lot of times so it wasn't
like you know once I was done I was done
when things got lean when things got
tough I did look several times I even
interviewed at some places so it wasn't
like I just left it but I was like but I
will never get to where I need to get to
if I do that if I do it I won't I won't
grow and so you know we have that's 20
2018 I'm sorry 2017 2018 most of the
Year again it was tough I mean I even
had to move back in with my mom it was
that bad
um and you know
it was it was a difficult situation and
then I got a phone call that they wanted
you know that uh Bounce TV wanted to
work with me about doing a musical for a
Christmas musical and I'm like Okay cool
so we started having some meetings and
back and forth it wasn't a lot of money
it was you know like
you know it wasn't a lot of money but it
was like my first opportunity so I went
ahead and you know and took it and then
it grew from there but uh that was like
the latter part of 2018 like
September so those first nine months of
2018 was tough it was tough but uh yeah
it's all come through and then 2019
comes and I I started making some money
I'm like oh wait a minute and and
actually was more money that I made in
um working with the city
um and then 2020 comes and then you know
obviously the the covert situation
everything shuts down and then we pick
that up again in like August
and that I made more money in 2020 in
four months that I made in uh in 2019.
so I'm like okay
you know I there's a light at the end of
the tunnel I I see that this actually
can work and I'm happy that that I did
not take those other jobs that I was on
the keys you know about to uh send me my
resume for
was there a feeling of you might lose
friends or acquaintances if you left
that world that corporate world
no I didn't feel like I was gonna lose
friends or acquaintances I wasn't really
friendly with a lot of the people there
let me clarify I'm friendly with
everyone but it's not like we we didn't
hang out you know I didn't do things
like that so no I it wasn't not a an
issue for me at all okay so it wasn't
like yeah you weren't going to lose you
know a circle of friends or nothing but
okay no no no no okay um I keep I mean
my circle of friends
are not necessary people that I work
with in the corporate world I mean I'm
friendly with everyone but we didn't
hang out my circle of friends and folks
that I used that I went to high school
with I mean those are folks I'm still
really tight we there's about seven or
eight of us
and um you know we we we talk once or
twice a week you know in group chats and
stuff like that so no my friends are are
people that I've grown up with since I
was eight uh 14 years of age